GENERAL HURTLING, PUTIN NOW
SAYS HE HAS NO DOUBT RUSSIA'S
GOALS WILL BE ACHIEVED AND SAYS
IT AS ZELENSKY IS IN
WASHINGTON.
SERGEI SHOIGU OF RUSSIA HAS ANNOUNCED A
MASSIVE INCREASE IN THE SIZE OF
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY FROM 1 TO
1.5 MILLION PERSONNEL.
OBVIOUSLY 100,000 OF THEM OR SO
WERE ALREADY DEAD IN UKRAINE,
BUT THEY'RE ANNOUNCING A MASS
INCREASE.
IS THIS REAL?
COULD THIS REALLY HAPPEN OR IS
IT TOTAL BLUSTER?
WHAT DO YOU THINK, GENERAL?
>> I THINK A LOT OF IT'S
BLUSTER.
>> YOU KNOW, THE POINT IS MR.
PUTIN CONTINUES TO ANNOUNCE WHAT
HE'S GOING TO DO IN TERMS OF
MOBILIZATION OF FORCES.
IN LAS VEGAS, ERIN, THIS IS
CALLED THROWING GOOD MONEY AFTER
BAD.
HE JUST CONTINUES TO ATTEMPT TO
MOBILIZE FORCES.
HE'S SEEN A GREAT RANGE WITHIN
RUSSIA ITSELF OF YOUNG 18 TO
24-YEAR-OLDS LEAVING THE COUNTRY
TRYING TO DEPART TO AVOID THIS
KIND OF STUFF.
HE HAS PROVEN DECIDEDLY THAT HE
DOES NOT HAVE THE EQUIPMENT.
THERE'S NO DOCTRINE THAT THE
SOLDIERS ARE FOLLOWING THAT'S
EFFECTIVE.
THEIR LEADERS ARE CORRUPT AND
IMMORAL, AND THEY ARE NOT --
THEY'RE ACTUALLY CONTRIBUTING TO
THE FAILURE AS OPPOSED TO
PREVENTING IT.
THERE'S A LACK OF ABILITY TO
ADAPT TO THE BATTLEFIELD
CONDITIONS, AND THE FINAL
THOUGHT IS ANY MODERN ARMY THAT
PERFORMS WELL ON THE BATTLEFIELD
HAS TRUST IN THEIR LEADERS,
THEIR EQUIPMENT, THEIR DOCTRINE,
AND THE SUPPORT OF THE PEOPLE.
THE RUSSIAN SOLDIERS DO NOT HAVE
THAT, SO IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW
MANY HE'S MOBILIZING.
IT JUST MEANS THAT MORE OF THEM
ARE GOING TO DIE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD.
>> SO ANDRE, YOU KNOW, THE
GENERAL TALKS ABOUT TRUST.
WE REALIZE IT DOES NOT EXIST IN
MANY CASES BETWEEN THE RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS THEMSELVES, BETWEEN
ONES WHO ARE ALREADY THERE AND
NEW CONSCRIPTS AND MANY OF THEM
AND THEIR COMMANDERS.
THAT LATEST INTERCEPTED PHONE
CALL -- AND I KNOW YOU AND I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT SO MANY OF
THESE.
BUT THE ONE WE JUST HEARD ABOUT
PEOPLE PULLING A 500 AND F-BOMB
AND I'M NOT FIGHTING ANYMORE,
I'M JUST WALKING OFF, THIS IS IN
LINE WITH SO MANY CALLS AND
VIDEOS THAT WE HAVE HEARD AND
SEEN THAT SHOW A DIRE SITUATION
AMONG THE RUSSIAN TROOPS.
MAJOR EQUIPMENT ISSUES PUTIN
KNOWS ABOUT ALL THIS.
DOES HE ANDRE, OR IS HE IN THE
DARK?
WHAT'S THE REALITY?
>> TODAY WHEN HE DECIDED TO HIS
MILITARY COMMANDERS HE LOOKED TO
BE DELUSIONAL.
IT LOOKS LIKE HE STILL BELIEVES
HE'S IN TOTAL CONTROL OF THE
WHOLE SITUATION.
HE CONSTANTLY WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE NEW OBJECTIVES FOR THE WAR,
THAT WE HAVE THIS CONFLICT FOR
CENTURIES, WE'RE GOING TO WIN,
WE'RE GOING TO INCREASE OUR
ARMY.
AND BECAUSE OF THE UNREST -- AND
THE PROBLEM IS SOME KIND OF
DISSENT HE HAD IN PUBLIC
OPINION, IN RUSSIAN SOCIAL MEDIA
ARE SUPPRESSED BY THE KREMLIN
AND RUSSIAN SECURITY SERVICES.
SO THE ONLY PICTURE WE CAN
ACTUALLY SEE IS COMPLETE
OBEDIENCE, AND THAT IS WHY HE
STILL BELIEVES THAT HE IS IN
CONTROL.
>> GENERAL, TODAY PUTIN SAID,
QUOTE, WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT AND IMPROVE THE
READINESS OF RUSSIA'S NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK PUTIN'S NEXT
MOVE WILL BE HERE.
HE'S BEEN SO CLEAR THERE WILL BE
ONE IN RESPONSE TO THE PATRIOT,
SO WHAT DOES HE DO?
>> WELL, HE -- HE'S NOT GOING TO
HAVE MUCH OF AN EFFECT ON THE
PATRIOTS TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
ERIN.
AS YOU TALKED TO SOME OF YOUR
LAST GUESTS ABOUT THE SIZE OF
THAT FORCE, THAT'S A RELATIVELY
SMALL BATTERY THAT'S GOING TO
HAVE PROBABLY SIX LAUNCHERS
AROUND UKRAINE -- I'M SORRY,
AROUND KYIV.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HEAVILY
GUARDED, AND HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO ATTACK THEM.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN MR. PUTIN AND
HIS MILITARY DO IS ATTACK MORE
OF THE CIVILIAN POPULATION THAN
HE HAS UKRAINE'S MILITARY.
SO, YOU KNOW, THE COMMENT ABOUT
CONTINUING TO POLISH HIS NUCLEAR
CAPABILITY IS SOMETHING THAT
HE'S BEEN SAYING AND THREATENING
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS WAR.
AND HE HAS MADE A LOT OF BAD
MISTAKES BOTH OPERATIONALLY,
TACTICALLY AND STRATEGICALLY.
THIS WOULD BE A HUGE MISSTEP ON
HIS PART.
AND I THINK HE KNOWS THE
REPERCUSSIONS FOR THE USE OF ANY
KIND OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS WOULD BE
CATASTROPHIC BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND OTHERS
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
TOLD HIM AND HIS ADMINISTRATION.
SO THIS IS JUST MORE THREATS,
MORE BLUSTER BY MR. PUTIN.
AND I SURE HOME HIS NUCLEAR
FORCE IS A LOT BETTER THAN HIS
CONVENTIONAL FORCE BECAUSE HIS
CONVENTIONAL FORCE HAS NOT SHOWN
ANY CAPABILITY WHATSOEVER.
>> THANKS TO BOTH OF YOU THIS
EVENING.